qu'est-ce qui se passe
charge de confrères l'accord partez
pendant qu'il est encore temps
ces images c'est que vous êtes dans la
santé
qui n'est plus sous contrôle du
gouvernement américain les garçons je
vous aime tous les deux tués cette
espèce
ils ont eu tort de s'attaquer à cette
famille commence elle a pu arriver ils
détiennent une nouvelle arme tout se
déconnecte plus rien ne fonctionne jusqu
au commandement central qu'est ce qu'on
peut faire
je vais me battre tous ceux qui veulent
me rejoindre sont les bienvenus on est
les wolverine et on sème le chaos
on doit voler cette arme je peux pas
détends toi mes appuis
nous avons hérité de la liberté à nous
de la défendre
ici c'est rien pour pour nous c'est
notre foyer